bonsoir avec six poulains merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
gouvernement qui semble donc changé de
stratégie de communication émise est
totalement sur les inférences heures
pour faire passer des messages
alors que faut-il en penser alors
totalement sur les influenceurs beaucoup
du moins et c'est assez inquiétant parce
qu'on est là en train de quitter le
champ du politique pour entrer dans le
champ du marketing les influenceurs ce
sont ces personnes plutôt jeunes qui
sont sur les réseaux sociaux vous en
avez parlé twitch instagram youtube
facebook twitter et autres et qui fédère
autour d'eux une communauté d'influencé
majoritairement pour vendre des produits
et là on a les politiques qui décident
finalement de pousser les journalistes
encore plus loin du cadre d'utiliser ces
influenceurs pour parler directement
auprès de ces communautés qui se
reconnaissent un retrait de leur
influence heures préféré et pour
délivrer des messages de propagande
politique puisque on est là dans la
propagande pure et simple
réactualisé avec les outils du 21e
siècle et ça c'est fait d'une manière
assez cynique puisque derrière ces
influenceurs ils ne sont pas seuls il ya
des entreprises avec beaucoup d'argent
notamment webedia par exemple qui
emploie mcfly et carlito web et dias et
400 millions de chiffre d'affaires c'est
la propriété de fimalac dont
l'actionnaire principal est marc ladreit
de lacharrière proches des malades mâcon
depuis qu'il a été élu es et mac faye
carlito vous les connaissez puisque
c'est à eux que le chef de l'état a fait
appel pour rappeler les gestes barrière
dans une vidéo tout ça est évidemment un
montage de communication avec wedia bien
entendu pour ensuite bien redorer
l'image d'emmanuel macron auprès des
plus jeunes où il va pouvoir se mettre
en scène de manière totalement
décomplexée et montrer une personnalité
autre que celle que l'on connaît
habituellement au près en plus d'un
public jeune qui n'a pas forcément les
outils pour décrypter et pour avoir une
vision un peu critique de cet exercice
politique puisque ça devient un exercice
politique mais
six nouveaux alexis alors c'est pas
vraiment nouveau parce que les hommes et
les femmes politiques ont toujours eu
besoin des influenceurs entre guillemets
il y a quelques années de cela avant les
réseaux sociaux et bien c'était les
stars de la musique ou du cinéma qui
prenait fait et geste pour les causes à
un johnny hallyday on se rappelle et
d'autres qui ensuite avait fait campagne
pour qui nicolas sarkozy qui françois
hollande etc
donc il est toujours un peu cette
peopolisation également du politique qui
se mettait en scène dans les pages des
journaux people que ce soit gala ou
autre d'ailleurs me marchand qui est
l'une des grande papesse de cette presse
people via son agence de photo est une
des amies de brigitte mâcon qui a donné
beaucoup de conseils à emmanuel macron
dans la campagne de 2017
ce qui change c'est qu'effectivement
l'utilisation de ces influenceurs
numérique cela qui utilisent les réseaux
sociaux est les industriels par la
république en marche
d'abord ça commence avec la campagne de
2017 ou google donne des conseils à ceux
qui s'occupaient de la campagne pour
voir comment utiliser ces influenceurs
comment parler aux jeunes comment
utiliser cette plateforme
et puis on a finalement un détournement
de des outils publics notamment le
service d'information du gouvernement
qui est là pour informer et qui va petit
à petit utiliser ces influenceurs pour
faire de la propagande partisane puisque
il est question là de mettre en scène la
personnalité la personne d'emmanuel
macron en tant que futur candidat à sa
réélection
mais c'est également le cas de gabriel
attal qui utilisent ces plateformes en
son nom personnel et pas du tout en tant
que porte parole du gouvernement
et là on est dans un trou juridique
assez grave parce que ça permet de
parler directement aux citoyens et
citoyennes aux plus jeunes en
particulier
sans être sous les yeux du csa sont être
comptabilisés en temps de parole
politique
il ya donc une façon de communiquer
directement qui pose question et puis et
puis c'est pas près de s'arrêter parce
que c'est pratique évidemment d'engager
comme ça des communautés en direct alors
il n'ya pas qu emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement dans ce cas que dire des
autres partis politiques et des autres
politiques en général oui alors c'est
sûr qu emmanuel macron est celui qui en
a fait un mode de goût
ornements moi je parle du gouvernement
des influenceurs et des influences euse
tellement c'est caricatural
parce que marlène schiappa va jusqu'à
aller sur tik tok alors soit disant pour
faire un clin d'oeil mais on voit que
toute la communication gouvernementale
tourne autour de cette notion d'
influence et de communication est très
peu finalement dans l'action ou même
dans la réflexion politique
mais avant lui bien d'autres ont utilisé
ces réseaux c'est le cas de jean luc
mélenchon qui est un précurseur en la
matière puisqu'il est maintenant à plus
de 500 milles abonnés sur sa chaîne
youtube
il a créé la revue de la semaine pour
parler en direct à ses partisans
chaque semaine il va maintenant crée
même un réseau social réservé aux
insoumis pour en cas de censure avoir un
réseau social où il pourra s'exprimer
librement
françois hollande vous en ai parlé qui
est allée qui fait un retour médiatique
sur twitch plutôt qu'ailleurs il était
aussi danseuse haïti et là on voit que
vous le dites castex monsieur castex va
lui aussi parlé chez samuel etienne sur
twitch incroyable tout est en train de
changer
et puis nicolas dupont aignan qui se
vantait d'être numéro 1 sur facebook
réseau plus âgés mais là encore une
façon de parler directement
le problème que ça pose l'utilisation de
ces plateformes c'est le poids politique
de ces plateformes et on l'a vu en
janvier lorsque twitter a décidé de
supprimer purement et simplement le
compte de donald trump président des
états unis alors qu'il était encore
président des états unis
c'était le cas aussi de facebook ces
plateformes ont un rôle politique énorme
en fonction du choix de l'algorithme du
choix de la façon dont elles vont
présenter l'information
elles vont faire monter certains
messages ou bien un visibiliser des pans
entiers finalement du débat politique
donc c'est un jeu à double tranchant
certains ont choisi d'ailleurs de migrer
vers d'autres plateformes comme parleurs
gab ou bien télégramme
mais reste que le poids des usages c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on utilise massivement
pour des messages politiques c'est plate
forme et ça ne risque pas de changer et
certains partis commencent à se rendre
compte qu'ils ont pris beaucoup de
retard par rapport à d'autres
c'est le cas notamment des républicains
qui risquent ces jours ci sans doute de
faire aussi beaucoup d'apparitions sur
twitch ou bien sûr club house le dernier
arrivé une sorte de podcasts live
un peu vip qui errent encore un des
nouveaux réseaux sociaux alors attention
contre cette politique des influenceurs
il ya un seul remède c'est la
politisation et l'esprit critique
on n'a pas fini en tout cas d'en parler
merci alexis et poulain rappelle comme
ça donc éditorialistes merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous